chair of the house weighs a mean i find
that due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor
as a result of the covered 19 pandemic
in
accordance with house rule 67 and the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a revenue with session please
note that there is no physical location
for members of the public to observe and
listen contemporariously to this meeting
however and according to the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporaries
through the zone electronic platform and
the public has access to contemporaries
listen and if necessary participate in
this meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice of this meeting complies with
the house rules irs
and rsa 91-a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call
271 3600 or email
hcbs at lake.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
i want to staff that around the meeting
assisting us
christopher shea and brad greenland yeah
brad is there
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by a roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking over
attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you
during this meeting which is required
representative bernstein you want to
take the role
thank you mr chair uh good morning
everyone it is february 23
2021 it's 9 a.m let's begin the roll
call with representative pat abrami
here in my home in stratham my wife's in
the house thank you
representative mary griffin
representative griffin
representative jordan owerry allman
hudson
wife is in the house representative
russell ober
home and hudson i understand i can't
mention caps though
representative doucette oh
omen salem alone representative bershkin
is your clerk he's in his home office in
nottingham new hampshire by himself
representative robert elliott president
and my wife is in the house
representative john ginidian president
in salem new hampshire i'm in my car but
i'll be in my home office in
approximately 30 seconds good
representative herschel nunes
marshall nunez is present in pelham at
home alone representative tim baxter
thank you representative i'm home alone
representative walter stillsbury
home alone in charlestown wife and kids
may come and go from time to time
representative paul tudor
home and northwood wife is in the house
representative army
i'm alone in lebanon representative
richard ames
yes i'm here in jeffrey in my home
office alone
representative tom southworth here in
dover
alone representative here in greenland
home alone representative schamberg
and my truck at concord headed back to
wilman
representative tucker i'm here in
randolph
alone representative gomarlo i'm here in
swansea alone
representative tom laughman
representative laughman
representative amanda gorg good morning
i am present and alone
representative mary hacken phillips
maria i'm present alone for my office in
concord
representative james murphy good morning
i am home in my
uh office alone in hanover thank you
representative
and chairman norman major good morning
i'm in my home in my office
and my wife is in the house mr chair
there are 22 members present
thank you representative uh
this morning christopher shay
was able to arrange to have the deputy
of the public health here this morning
to talk about
the covert 19 and what effect it could
have on our economy
and various other things and to answer
questions
good morning everyone thank you thank
you chair major thank you committee
members
i have some slides today so i was
wondering if um
i would be able to share them through
screen
jenny can you i'm going to
shoot this one to brad if she doesn't
see the green
share screen icon then i don't know
i got it you just let me in so thank you
so much so
i'm going to ineligently try and do this
i'm never quite
good at it getting it going but um we'll
we'll get it started here to the best of
my
ability so i think what you should be
seeing
right now is um a slide deck is that
correct
true yes yes look it looks right
perfect thank you so very much um
well welcome well thank you so much for
the second invitation
i am gonna plan on sharing um
some state and national trends and then
shift into a little bit of a deeper dive
into vaccines
and again focus on what this might mean
for the economy i anticipate that you're
going to have some questions
um some i will be able to answer and
uh some i may need to get out a crystal
ball for
um so i'd love to jump right into the
numbers i'm actually going to
turn off my video while i'm doing the
slides
simply uh for bandwidth issues i'm
coming to you live
from our public health covid operations
center which is not one of our regular
buildings and and the
internet is sometimes a little bit shaky
so i'm going to stop my video i'll pop
my video back on when we have time for
questions so great
thank you so much and i'm going to um
then jump right into the numbers here we
go
so i think in front of you you should
have a slide with a little bit of
national data
um although the cases have been trending
downward across the country
for some time um after our post holiday
spike
yes it's not showing you haven't gone to
the next slide
okay thank you for letting me my
screen sharing has been paused
okay here if i can
slide two okay
[Music]
um let's see here i i
am not understanding why my screen
sharing is
paused so i'm going to stop
sharing i'm going to start over and see
if that will help
um okay
greg can you help her out
i would thank you about to suggest that
she stopped turning her screen and try
again
um might be a good resume okay
no no no no
um for some reason the zoom is letting
me know that it's paused and it won't
let me
share
so we're going to do this a third time
here try to see if that is the
charm
you know what i will go ahead and just
let you know the data that we have
um and see if we can do it that way
um because i don't want to waste your
time today
so um we'll see if we can get those
slides in a little bit but i don't want
to
waste your um your really precious time
at this moment
so um here let me tell you a little bit
about the numbers
so our cases have been trending
downwards as you know um
and yesterday we passed really the
solemn
mark of 500 000 american deaths
this is about a hundred thousand more
deaths
than when the last time that i've i came
to visit you that you invited me to
speak with you
and this number has actually impacted
our life expectancy
in the u.s it's reduced it by more than
a year
and certainly 500 000 deaths is not the
worst case
projection that was considered a year
ago but
i think all of us would agree that it is
definitely too many lives
and it's heartbreaking for those of us
who have needlessly lost
our neighbors our friends and our family
and the
cost and burden to our communities and
to our families
cannot be fully measured in dollars
or in this data alone as we look at the
new hampshire data
you'll recognize and if i had my little
slide here you would see the giant
spike that many of us have been seeing
on tv and in the media
and that occurred between thanksgiving
20 and january 2021.
the good news in that as has been widely
described
is that our active case count now is
below
3 000 and our current hospitalizations
are
just above 100. this is remarkably
different than where we were
back in january where we had over 300
people in the hospital at the time
we were really pushing the limits of
some of our hospitals and some of our
icus
we never got to a critical moment but we
really were pushing the edges of it
and coming very close so while the
current numbers are still
too high we really are experiencing a
relief to our health care system now
most recently you can note that the high
rates of cases
in new hampshire are located in
stratford county
many of those are associated with the
university students that came back on
campus
um as i'll note later unh's
testing protocol has helped identify
those cases quickly and investigations
have
indicated that those cases likely didn't
come from formal class settings
but rather informal gatherings if
you understand you'll see that we also
had higher rates in grafton county
recently
again similarly many of these have been
associated with the college
while the college cases are starting to
go down now again
great news um they have gone um and this
mainly because um some of those
universities unh
plymouth have gone back to some remote
learning
um we could note that about even
yesterday about 15
of our daily case count was associated
with a college or a university
another thing for just important for us
to think about as you think about the
current economy and the workforce
individuals ages
20 to 29 have both the highest
cumulative number of cases of cobin 19
and the highest rate and that's compared
to other
age cohorts it's important to note that
these cases are
found among all working age adults
these are folks that work in our
industries and in our businesses and
then
go home to their families the good news
is that the lowest rates are among the
younger children
in addition to colleges we continue to
identify
small clusters in workplaces workplaces
such as manufacturing
restaurants and retail continue to have
small outbreaks some of the other good
news and certainly that we've all
recognized
is the trend line among cases in
long-term care facilities
that we have the same pattern there if
again if i had my slides up you would
see the fancy graph where we would go
we spiked up in december and then
started to come down in january
the downward slide however for long-term
care facilities is even a little bit
more impressive
than the general public and this is
likely due to the vaccine efforts that
began in december
within those long-term care facilities
with our partners
in both cvs and walgreens that work
directly with those long-term care
facilities
so that they have um the residents of
long-term care have received both doses
right now certainly if you had been a
resident as of december or january you
received both doses
and we're working on the continuation as
new residents come in
and staff turnover making sure that
those
facilities have access to as much
vaccine as they need
we are all very relieved to see that
these numbers have
started to go down among the most
vulnerable new hampshire residents
who really were most at risk for the
worst outcomes
of coved 19. so while we're feeling
cautiously optimistic about the downward
trends and daily counts again our number
you know our accounts are going down we
have 200 some odd cases today we were
routinely
um just a couple of weeks ago we were in
the three and four hundreds and even
weeks before that
we were at 600 700 800 cases a day
so those numbers are starting to come
down nicely
and we are very excited by the
reductions in both hospitalization the
census in the hospital
as well as deaths of course we do
know that we are in our race a little
bit against
spread of those new variants we all know
that viruses constantly change over time
and through mutation
and variants of a virus are really
expected to occur sometimes these new
variants emerge
and disappear and sometimes the new
and persist right now we are focused on
three major variants b117
is known as the uk variant that i'm sure
you've been hearing about on the news
of the three variants this is the one
most prevalent in the u.s
right now with over 1600 documented
cases
in over 44 states including new
hampshire
the new hampshire resident who was
infected with this variant
was an adult resident of hillsborough
county and they had had close
contact with someone who was diagnosed
with covid19
who had been traveling internationally
contact tracing was identified and close
household contacts were
were also identified but no community
exposures
were identified all of the public health
measures of isolation quarantine testing
were followed including the testing of
all of the close whole
household context and so it's not
believed that there was a risk
to the community from this particular
case
quick testing and following those
protocols
helped contain the spread in south
africa there's another variant
called the b1351 and it emerged
independently of the uk variant the b117
um it was identified back in october
in south africa we have 22
cases in the u.s right now in 10 states
um since early january and finally
there's a p1
variant which is the third variant and
that one's known as the brazil variant
because it was found
in travelers who were traveling from
brazil
back in early january only five cases
of have been identified in the u.s so
far
it appears that these variants seem to
spread more easily and
some data is suggesting that the
symptoms may be worse
especially among unvaccinated
individuals
data especially from the uk where the
uk variant is widely spreading
is suggesting that the current vaccines
the pfizer and the moderna
are effective in reducing death
and severe disease and hospitalization
among those with a uk variant so they
may get it
but the symptoms are less and really the
things that we're most concerned about
which is hospitalization and death
do not seem to occur if people have been
vaccinated
with the current pfizer and moderna
vaccines
so while all this data on uh cases is
important
and those variants are important to keep
in the back of your mind i think one of
the things that you're most con
interested in is an update on the
vaccines
as we all know we have been rolling out
vaccine
distribution since late december and we
have hit
some bumps in the road which again have
been widely publicized
we have been actively trying to address
those issues as they come along
and keep readjusting we have more than 4
000 people a day
coming through our vaccine sites all
across
the state we redeployed state workers to
answer
phones we've taken over empty mall space
where i am right now and parking lots we
have specialized
teams on meeting the needs of homebound
patients
on individuals who have been
disproportionately
affected by covet we have a number of
really focused teams trying to get
to those folks that might be most at
risk of not being able to access
vaccine and i i simply want to note that
we could not do this work
without the national guard our health
care providers
and our community partners we cannot
extend enough gratitude
in their direction they have all been
extraordinary
in helping us with the rollout that we
have today
we are still in phase 1b and we have
some work to go
in phase 1b but as
march draws nearer we have our eyes and
our
planning hats all focused on the next
phase which is phase
two which will include those teachers
and child care workers
as well as individuals between 50
and age 64. so again 1b
we know that's the 65 and older group
and it's those folks that have multiple
comorbidities and that's who's rolling
through our vaccine sites right now
as appointments and vaccine become
available we call people up on the phone
and we get them in in line
we've administered about 74
of the 324 324
000 doses that we have received as of
last thursday
12 of new hampshire's population has
received one dose
and about five percent of the population
has received
both of their doses and are now fully
vaccinated
each day thousands more people are
receiving that vaccine and state
approximately 37
of those eligible in phase 1a and phase
1b which is
um you know the total number in those
groups is about 438 000 people
has gotten one dose so about 37 of that
438 000 people
have gotten one dose there have been
a number of questions um about
the what percentage of adults must be
vaccinated
in order to receive you know get to some
sort of
herd immunity many epi models
and experts like dr fauci have suggested
that it's something
close to herd immunity occurs around 75
of individuals vaccinated but even with
these experts in the mathematical
modeling
we unfortunately can't predict exactly
what vaccination rate will be needed to
return to sort of
some sense of normal there are just
too many questions about the coronavirus
that we simply
cannot answer right now and those
questions are things like
people who are vaccinated could still
pose some small risk of
spreading the virus even though the
vaccines protect them from serious
illness and hospitalization and death
they still may be able to spread we need
to see the real world examples of what
that might look like
not just the mathematical modeling and
because
no vaccine is a 100 effective um
some vaccinated people may still get ill
and could again
could still pass on the disease and then
of course that we have the variance
so we have all of these things that are
making
you know that prognostication difficult
right now our governor stated last week
at his press conference
um that he actually didn't fully expect
that we would get to 75 percent of the
population vaccinated and that we
probably should always expect to have
some level of covet
within the community but the good news
is that with enough
people taking that vaccine we will see
other
data points move we will see those daily
case counts go down
we will see the number of people in the
hospital go down
and the number of deaths go down and
those are all
equally important to the magic
percentage that
of people vaccinating vaccinated
reopening
will not necessarily be tied to just
one data point as all of these numbers
go
down and vaccinations go up it's clear
that we are protecting the most
at risk and we will begin to see more
flexibility in how we can live work
and play vaccine is one of the most
important tools we'll have in the
toolbox but it is
not the only tool uh for the time being
we will still need to test
like crazy i think we saw that in the
past few weeks at unh and plymouth how
important that testing strategy really
is
um and it helps us identify where we
have pockets and where we need to really
focus
additional effort the testing allows us
to isolate
and quarantine folks to further prevent
spread
we are currently testing somewhere over
000 people a day in a variety of
settings
so our eyes really need to be on several
metrics that we needed there
where eyes need to be on back deep new
cases
hospitalizations and deaths and so while
some of us have our eyes on that data
it's also clear that folks like our
governor's reopening task force
have their uh and and also many
businesses have their eyes
on the summer um guidance will soon be
released for things like summer camp
which is pretty exciting for kids and
families
so that our kids can get back outside
and parents can have the child here that
they need and i think that
as this committee you understand the
child care that that families really
need
other guidance will start coming out of
that task force soon and with the
governor's off the governor's blessing
around um helping restaurants and
lodging
you know again continue to evolve and be
able to serve their
their public and their clients and their
customers
and as more and more vaccines we have
more and more vaccine we anticipate that
people
will be able to travel a little bit more
broadly to the beach or to the mountains
or
to our main streets which i know is what
you all
are concerned about the vaccines begin
to give us
a little bit of freedom to do the many
of the things that we really
want to do and we have been missing
outdoor activities this summer are still
going to be the safest
but that's probably what we do best in
new hampshire
even our performing arts venues are
beginning to be incredibly
creative to be able to produce the kind
of events
that are safe for both their performers
and their staff and the public go for
funds and other supports have enabled
businesses to adjust
and stay on track and really be able to
meet
some of the things that they need to do
with this guidance things like focus on
their ventilation systems
focusing on changing some of the ways in
which
they also do their business we've
learned that things like child
care infrastructure is critically
important if we want businesses and
people
to be able to work i think
as we plan for phase two again for child
care workers and teachers
um and people 50 to 64.
one of the main things that we have to
do within the department and with our
partners is short up that registration
system
again we've all known the hiccups that
we've occurred we've had to work with a
clunky
federal system we've had a sort of build
our system at the same time
and make those systems talk together um
and there certainly have been hiccups
along the way and so when we're thinking
about
getting ready for phase two we want that
to go even more
smoothly and so we're putting in the
effort around the clock right now
getting ready for that the feds have
also indicated that
additional vaccines will be on the way
johnson and johnson vaccine should be
available soon you'll recall that's the
one doser
it has a little slightly less efficacy
than the pfizer and the moderna that we
have now but experts are really telling
us
um that it's first of all any vaccine is
better than no vaccine
and what's most important about all of
these vaccines
is the ability to reduce severe illness
and keep us out of the hospital
and keep us from dying and johnson and
johnson does that well
as well but it requires us to be
thinking about different ways
that we do the logistics around
getting that those doses out once they
come here
we are currently considering ways to
increase the throughput at our vaccine
centers
especially as we wrap up the efforts for
some of the most vulnerable people that
are in phase 1a and phase 1b
we are looking at additional ideas of
perhaps doing some indoor
centers we are starting right now this
week up in
lebanon using an old jc penney's that
has been closed we will be starting
there doing indoor
vaccination we think that that will
improve the throughput we'll be able to
get people
faster through those um indoor sites and
especially again as we get to phase two
and we have a broader section of
population we think that that's probably
the best way to go
that'll be both safe and effective in
getting the numbers through that we
would like to get through
especially if we get more doses from the
feds soon
so we're busy scoping out empty retail
sites across the state
empty parking lots and others so that we
can get things set up ready to go
you know again i want to say that the
logistical support of the national guard
has been critical to our success when
you get your vaccine as i hope many of
you already have or
or you're planning to please be sure to
thank
them and the volunteers and the first
responders who
have been helping get things rolling out
and get those shots
into arms so i'll wrap up with just a
reminder
that if folks have questions if your
constituents have questions
to call 2-1-1 we know that there are
sometimes long waits
and we're sometimes put on hold for a
little while but those folks are working
um crazy hours right now to get in touch
with everybody that they need to get in
touch with
um we're pulling people up earlier that
had later appointments we're trying to
get them into earlier appointments
uh we're working with places like
ammunition community health center up in
littleton
who just found out from the feds that
they'll be receiving some
some vaccine we've been working with
walgreens who has
also received some vaccine and so we're
really working in a coordinated way
to get as many people through as quickly
as possible
so we can all have our eyes on what we
hope will be a summer
um that we can get outside and we can
get back to doing some of the things
that we all love to do so um
again i will wrap up there i thank the
committee for asking us to come and do
this update
um you may have some additional
questions for me
thanks thank you patricia uh
your slides even though we didn't get to
see them you
send yes i'll send them a lot i'll email
them along
all right thank you uh questions for
the deputy started with representative
bromley
followed by representative elni thank
you patricia good good presentation
uh so we're currently at 4 000 a day is
that correct
yeah between 4 thousand and five
thousand a day depending on the day
so you know uh like right after we had a
snow day
our numbers bumped way up um you know
but
it's somewhere in in that ballpark so
what's the goal now though
you said that we're going to try to gear
up so that we can do more than four
what would that goal be to be more than
4 000 a day
yes so wha what kind of a goal are we
talking about
um so um i don't have that number right
in front of me
right now i mean what we want to do is
get move
out as much of the vaccine that we get
in
every day so we are dependent on what
the supply chain is coming in from the
feds
um i think the numbers you know knowing
that we have
um some promises for increased vaccine
coming
soon um the idea is to get to those
other kind of sites where we can improve
that daily throughput
and um i don't have that number you know
the exact goal for you right now but
um we know that we have large numbers of
people in
phase two that we need to move through
and so that the current rate that we're
going right now
is insufficient but again it is limited
by the number of vaccine we actually
have
okay thank you representative followed
by representatives
1b is reserving spots
in may at this point on
i know because i spent a long time on
2-1-1
and then got a very nice national guard
person
who told me that on told me that
and told me that there was absolutely no
way
that anybody who was more severely at
risk than the general over 65 population
could indicate that anywhere so that
they could be called
earlier this is an answer i've been
getting
everywhere i've tried and there seems to
be
informal systems going on
to allow on people to sign
sign up on local lists and
somebody local would then be able to
call you when there was left over a
vaccine
those lists are accompanied by people
saying oh we shouldn't be
my hospital because vams doesn't
like it is um refuses to participate in
anything like that
on i do not understand
are we going to wait till after may to
start going to two
or are that is two going to start coming
in
in the middle of 665 and older
on and keep people who really
need it uh from
being able to get it because they got
signed up for me and uh
i mean it's i'm i'm in lebanon
it's great news about jcpenney but we
nobody here seems to know anything about
that
or how you would get on
get people who need to be gotten except
for we do know
under 65 works better and that must be
because you're using the state system
rather than the vam system but the van
system
is really getting in the way of the
people that need it most
so you have a whole series of questions
there you should
probably answer they were all
connected to each other and are the
result of two months of real frustration
thank you thank you thank you
representative almi
and um thank you for sharing that and we
distinctly aware of the incredible
frustration that the public is feeling
right now especially
among populations 65 and older trying to
get their vaccine and trying to
you know get those appointments moved up
we are actively every day
taking people off the bottom of that you
know the way bottom of that list
the folks that have appointments in
april um the folks that
may have an appointment in may reaching
out to them and trying to put them back
up at the top of the list as new
appointments
open um so you know the uh
switch from the art lebanon armory over
to the pennies
site um and i i live in the upper valley
as well so i know that
uh area quite well it's a it's a great
location we're really happy to be able
to have it
um is really in preparation
again for the time at which we are going
to have more vaccine and more
appointments available we are committed
to getting through this one
b group to the best degree possible
before we take on more
uh folks so and we are also committed to
shoring up those systems those
those database systems so that people
can have a better experience in
scheduling their appointments and
getting those appointments ready
i thank you for the time that you spent
on 2-1-1 we know we have
100 literally hundreds of national guard
and state staff right now answering
those phones
um and again we know the lines are the
the weight can be long sometimes but
they're um they're very friendly and
very
um helpful once you once you get a hold
of them
um as we know we can't fully um we have
to work
with the vam system it's the cdc system
it's what's tied
you know we have to tie into that to
some degree
so i don't have a magic answer for you
right now other than we are
dedicated every day we've got folks
making phone calls one after another to
try and move people up into earlier
spots
we were able to move a bunch of people
you know a couple thousand people
from those later slots into getting um
shots at walgreens because walgreens has
gotten a federal contract
to have some doses so we were one of the
only states that have worked and working
hand in hand with our pharmacy partner
to be able to take care of the people
who were at the end of the list
and get them moved up towards the
beginning so those are the sort of
strategies
that we're putting in place the other
note the thing that you noted about
people having informal lists
um it's uh you know i know that there's
been some
confusion in the communities because our
major effort has really been the state
fixed
sites but we also have our public health
networks in each of our regions around
the state
who are working within communities to
try and get
at some organism to places where people
might have
not have as much access so there are
some different ways
people are getting vaccinated so they
may those public health networks might
be working with a senior center
um or maybe working in other communities
instead
in other um working with a church there
so those folks have have also been
trying to get
vaccine out um the best that they can
but that's certainly not the
overwhelming number of vaccines that are
going out right now
so all i can say right now is that it
has been imperfect
we are working on it 24 7 to try and
make it
more perfect um and really dedicated to
getting people
off that bottom of that list and getting
a vaccine sooner
thank you representative early followed
by representative elliot
thank you i have uh three questions one
i'd like to know what your definition of
a case is
when um i was undergoing paramedic
training there was a very
specific definition that doesn't seem to
be
the case now the second question
is um regarding the uk variant that has
been discovered
the way the press portrayed it was that
it was
rampant found in new hampshire oh my god
it's going to
kill all you know that kind of stuff
but i didn't hear anything from your
office saint no
as you gave a very nice uh presentation
here
these people followed protocol and
there's no
there's not believed to be any community
exposure um
i haven't heard that publicly
perhaps it's not being done by your
office
more likely wmur doesn't see a headline
in it
and i haven't heard anything yet about a
reaction rate
to any of the uh vaccines that have been
offered thus far
although nationwide and worldwide
there's been
um as much as a 10
serious reaction rate um have you
noticed any of that in new hampshire
thank you for my questions great thanks
so you've got three
questions right there i'll start with
the case numbers so
we use this commonly among our
epidemiology
groups and and with cdc um to
you describe people we count as having a
particular condition so in this case
coven
we follow the national case definition
um
for this the covet 19 infection um
and that is set by cdc so they create
the definition
and we use that as we um
that's what meets our case definition um
there are other uh diseases and
conditions that get counted
similarly in this ways like salmonella
or tuberculosis
so it really is it's our count but what
gets defined as the case you know
um has a is a little bit more of a
complex process of
um you know meeting the particular
laboratory standards
or other presumed standards so i'm i'd
be happy to
i don't i was just trying to pull that
up and again i'm not i can't
do 50 things at once right now but i'd
be happy to send you the case definition
from cdc when i'm done
off here of what it of um who gets
counted in that
but we're really just using cases that
the case definition is just our count
um personal identification i would
appreciate the uh
definition being sent out thank you yeah
absolutely and
i'm it's hard for me to do two or three
things at the same time right now
um so um i'm gonna follow up on your
and your second question was um and i
just lost my train of thought again
because i was trying to google while i
was
was talking could you just remind me
again your second question
i apologize for that but thank you very
yeah the uk variant so if you look to
our
um press release that we put out when it
happened it actually
did have some of that information in
there that there was really no
um we there was no cause for community
exposure or cause for concern about
community exposure because in this case
people did the right thing they were
sick
they got tested um it was no there was a
as part of that investigation they noted
that the person that they
had had close contact with had had
international travel
um that also was part of what allowed us
to do the detail
of genomic surveillance on the test um
to see
and to identify that it was the uk
variant so again
um you know this is relatively good news
we knew eventually we were going to
see one of these variants for a number
of weeks
there were cases identified in
massachusetts new york
um vermont even had one i i believe
um you know so we were surrounded by it
so it was only time that we would
we would find that case um so i agree
um you know there was not a significant
cause for alarm
in new hampshire it's important to know
it's an important piece of information
for everybody to have
in just their awareness about why things
like wearing masks is still
important social distancing is important
as well as vaccine and your third
question again if you could just remind
yeah that was the reaction rate oh the
reaction rate so the reaction rate is
um uh we don't have new hampshire
specific data at this point so what will
happen and many of you who've had your
vaccine
might know this um you sign in
you're invited to sign up to something
called theirs which is the
vaccine adverse event reporting system
through cdc
um i was fortunate enough to have my own
vaccine so you type in what your
how you're feeling every day and what
your reactions are
um i can say that we have not had any
significant events
at our testing sites of sort of
immediate anaphylaxis
events we have had some people that
we've watched and we've monitored and
we've connected them with their
healthcare provider
but we are we don't have new hampshire
specific data yet
around what the adverse events might be
here
in new hampshire the data that you were
suggesting around 10
um you know is is perhaps in the
ballpark and it also defines what you
know depends what you mean by
an adverse event whether it's a
life-threatening adverse event
or the sort of reaction that we all
expect especially
after that second dose the second dose
punches a wallop
um as the media has told you and perhaps
your friends and family have experienced
um you know some percentage of people
will end up with a fever
um with soreness with swollen lymph
nodes
with you know fatigue um it's been our
experience that usually clears up within
a day or so
um you know one to three days and that
you know it goes away
i will personally share i also got sort
of got a wallop
on my second dose um and it was 20 hours
of feeling pretty punky
um and then i woke up and i was fine um
so
um you know for many folks that's a
small price to pay for
um the benefit of vaccination so thank
you and thanks for
repeating the questions for me no
problem thank you mr chair
representative elliott followed by
representative murphy represent ellie
you need to unmute
represent elliott unmute yourself okay
i did it thank you uh for taking my
question madam director
and uh i got my appointment
because we state reps have a lot of pull
i got my appointment last week
and it's for april 24th
which by my way of counting is two
months
so with all of the pull that we have
would you say that that's the normal
time
for people without pull to
get an appointment two months is that
correct
do you have any statistics on that yeah
um we are seeing um
people you know uh there's no magic way
to get a vaccine
um unlike to be honest other states that
have
you know counties and cities all doing
different things we have
you know for good or bad new hampshire
has a much more centralized approach
right now
what we are um it is not you know
unusual for someone
to get an appointment date that that is
that far out
um but what as i noted to representative
almi a little bit earlier what we're
doing is trying to pull people off the
back of that list
um as we have appointments pop open
earlier or as especially if we have new
vaccine
additional vaccine we are trying to pull
people off that later
list and get them settled into an
earlier appoint time every day i hear
people say yep the national guard folks
gave me a call
so i really encourage everyone who gets
a phone call
on on their smartphone and it says new
hampshire health department
pick up the phone um because it usually
means you've got some good news
um that they are trying to reschedule
you
so um hold tight you um one of the
things you can always do
is try and call 2-1-1 as well it's as i
said it's a it's a
really quite frankly almost unacceptable
wait time sometimes to get
through but if you have the time to sit
um sometimes
they can be able to help you um with
those appointments and see if there's
excuse me for interrupting but are you
saying that yes
the normal waiting time is two months
i say i'm saying that that has not been
unusual
so we have had people when people signed
up in january we
can test the next week
if it's not unusual than
it's usual so the answer is yes
is that correct it is correct that
some people have had to wait that long
it is also correct that some people have
not represented
earlier she's answered your question
please thank you
uh representative murphy followed by
representative nunes
thank you mr chairman and thank you
patricia my question is
more to do with the new state system
as representative almi mentioned the
frustration that
i have experienced but i think many of
my neighbors and friends have
experienced is that
there's a significant disconnect between
2-1-1
and those folks are great they're very
nice the wait time has not been that
problematic if you call later in the day
and they're very nice but they're not
helpful in the sense that if
you have to change it or it is canceled
for some reason
they will suggest you go back into vans
and you could
lose an appointment and then go into
outer space into may june or july
and that's not going to be acceptable my
question is regarding the
new state system number one when is it
coming on board
will there be a voice a real person that
you can talk to
who can actually make an appointment and
schedule an appointment for you
including the follow-up appointment if
need be
because so many people like at dh in and
out down in boston i know because my
daughter got it
will they be able to after you get the
first injection
give you that on the spot a follow-up
appointment so my questions really
surround the new system coming
on board when and how uh effective
and user-friendly will it be so
we are um developing it as we speak we
do not have a go live date right now
because i think we've all learned that
uh
and and it's just good business sense
not to launch something until it's ready
so we don't have a date for it to to go
live we know that we need to have it
ready for
um for phase two um i'm gonna circle
back and answer one of your other
questions around second appointments
one of the things that has been
happening now for the past couple of
weeks is that you get your second
appointment
um as you receive your first dose so
you're given that appointment right away
so that you get
within that four week window so we have
solved we've done some back-end changing
and been able to solve that
problem that people were having earlier
on
um in late january and the beginning of
february where
they would have to go out and get back
on vans and the second appointment was
you know two months away instead of the
recommended three or four weeks
so we have solved that problem sort of
check mark that and we will continue
that
as we move forward um with the new
system so that second appointments or
should not be
an issue um one of the you know you've
highlighted one of the features of the
van system that we have not been able to
get around which is the i have to cancel
my appointment to see a new appointment
and that's certainly a piece of
functionality that we're trying to work
on
the logistics um we have folks from
deloitte working with us
and others um so that we're ready to go
and be able to be more have more
flexibility
um for when we start enrolling
the larger groups that are coming in in
phase two
um and also so that we can help the rest
of
um phase 1b get their vaccine so
i don't have a go live day we're working
on it right now it needs to be done
before we go to phase two
um and um the follow-up appointments are
taken care of right now
manually um the minute you get your
first notes
just a quick follow-up if i may oh um
i personally got my appointment you know
for tomorrow
but as soon as i found out on the 20th
of january or whenever it was i got it
four weeks ago
i went home that afternoon i tried to
make an appointment i got it in
claremont the earliest would be tomorrow
that was well before we knew we had the
sessions going on so
you know it's it's just difficult to
rearrange through the vm system so
the sprinter that comes up and running
the better it's going to be for people
logistically
yeah we we agree 100
that it's been a challenge um it's just
been a challenge so thank you
i appreciate that and good luck on your
your vaccine tomorrow you should get
your second dose appointment right then
representative is followed by
representative tucker
thank you mr chairman and thank you miss
tilly for being with ways and means this
morning
i have a question for you about
continued vaccinations
today johnson johnson goes before the
feds today
uh they'll be presenting to energy and
commerce about
licensing for their vaccine they have a
promise of being able to deliver 20
million vaccines
this is a more traditional type of
vaccine than what is being offered right
now
and they also have a promise that they
would have another 100 million ready by
the end of june
now what i want to know from
from you today is is new hampshire uh
in the planning for receiving this more
traditional vaccine
in our state uh and if so how would that
be distributed and will our residents
have a choice of the type of vaccine
that they can that they can have will
they be able to request it
or are they going to be forced to take a
certain type of vaccine
and thank you yes those are great
questions thank you representative nunes
um so yeah the answer to your question
is yes we are planning
um tremendously right now um trying to
get ready for what this will mean
logistically
when we have access to the johnson and
johnson vaccine and again
i think all of us know on this call um
that's a one-jabber not a two-jabber
um like pfizer and modernist so
logistically it makes things a little
bit easier
um and distribution can be um we can
think about that in a much more
broad sense as as we move forward we do
not have a number yet
um from the feds um of what our first
doses
might actually be there's lots of
conjecture out there
the industry has given some numbers but
we do not have a number
yet from um our federal partners of what
that might look like
um you know it certainly is a firm
number
of what those first allocations will be
to your question around um how are we
deciding and how are we planning we're
doing a couple of things we have
our folks that are doing the logistics
of that um within the department of what
that might look like
in our vaccine distribution
we've also been meeting with something
called the state disaster medical
advisory committee it's called the sd
mac because every govern government
agency loves an acronym so the
sd mac has been meeting in an emergency
meeting last week
to talk about johnson and johnson to
really start weighing some of the
ethical and logistical questions about
who
gets these shots as i noted in my
presentation
the efficacy rate is a little bit less
in johnson and johnson um
you know experts are telling us that in
reality
um you know it's just as good as trump
as the uh spiezer moderner in terms of
this deer you know
you don't get seriously ill and you
don't get hospitalized and the risk of
death is very very low
but um it is you know the numbers are
what they
are there is a difference in terms of
just prevalence and case prevalence
um so that's entering into our um
conversations around
what types of groups of people would be
better suited for at johnson and johnson
versus
pfizer or germa and those are complex
decisions and i don't think we've
landed on a firm um
a firm plan moving forward um i think
logistically it would be sort of
difficult to drive through
your drive-through vaccine site and sort
of uh
an array of vaccine were put in front of
you and you know do you want the pfizer
do you want the maternity
do you want the johnson and johnson that
that becomes um
complicated in terms of you know knowing
how many
appointments to schedule um and you know
what happens if you're first in line
that day versus
last decline that day when we're dealing
with such limited doses so you've
hit on all the right questions and
unfortunately i don't have
final answers for you because we are in
the midst of doing that work right now
follow it mr chairman okay uh
thank you sir uh and miss tilly thank
you for those answers
i want to clarify down to a certain
point of
uh you just stated to us that that
logistically
and looking at demographics that that
you
guys would be working to make choices
about how those would be distributed
my question was about choice for the
resident yeah
will the resident be able to have choice
of the type of vaccine that they want
i think that's what we're we're working
on right now is figuring out what that
might look like and how you would
how you could possibly make that happen
so i don't have an answer of
yes no exactly how that would be done
because we're trying to figure that out
given the
small numbers we anticipate having um
how you could um again
logistically make those choices
available to folks
or what recommendations we would make
for people are there certain populations
we would recommend
one over the other um you know this is a
a little bit different than say our flu
vaccine right now where you talk with
your provider there's several different
ways
to get flu vaccine but there's enough
product out there
that you can choose them um and so you
know
these those are some of the limiting
factors that we have in our planning
right now
is how to manage um some of the
appropriate clinical choices that people
would have to make
um you know potentially with their
providers input
um or just their own of what their
preference is they're
you know say you're needle phobic and
i'm not gonna get a vaccine if i gotta
do it twice but you know you can get me
once
um and so that's that's what we're
working on right now these are
really the the tough questions um and
the tough planning that's going on
today thank you mr thank you miss tilly
represent tucker
followed by representative southwood
thank you so much for uh answering our
questions
i never thought i had uh constituents
who
would write or email or phone but i
turned out to be wrong
this is uh kovit has brought out the
constituents
but i'm interested in getting back a
little more to uh
uh ways and means kinds of questions do
you have
any idea of what likely
are apt to be the rules of the road so
to speak
in august do we think that they're going
to be able to be large
larger weddings or gatherings these are
the things that
particularly in the north country where
i live
the summer season is a very important
economic one
and people are wondering should they be
hiring people should they
be taking reservations and probably
you're in one of the better positions to
have an
answer to what we can expect
in august and september in the way of
how distancing people have to stay
whether you think they'll still be asked
to wear masks
thank you representative tucker and the
audio was a little um
low on that so i will um if i miss
anything please let me know
so i think you're asking a great
question and that's really sort of the
crystal ball question all of us have is
what's the summer really going to look
like um in some ways i think we can be
sure that um you know we will still be
thinking about mass squaring and social
distancing to some capacity
um so i don't think things will be 100
like it was in 2019
but uh the data is certainly indicating
right now
as we continue to have the increase in
vaccine uptake
and the decrease in daily case counts
and hospitalizations and deaths
that there may be some opportunities for
some more flexibility than we had
in the summer of 2020. we have been
the governor's reopening task force has
been hard at work on this thinking about
what that might be i know i've spoken
with the hampton beach
chamber of commerce as they're thinking
about
what um what sort of events what what
they could be planning for um
the notion that outdoors is best is
probably something good that we can all
sort of take to the bank at this moment
that
you know outdoors is better than indoors
um
but that they're you know my you know
guess is that there will likely be
increased flexibility from where we were
last summer
where that line will be you know we will
work closely with the task force in the
governor's office
and the governor you know will have the
ear of dr ben chan
and they will make some of those sort of
fine line decisions about
you know what's the the number of people
that can be gathering together
or you know exactly how um
things work but you know i am i'm taking
great
um comfort in the creative planning
that's happening among businesses
everywhere i've been working with
some performing art venues um thinking
about different ways that they do their
work you know whether it's a summer
stock playhouse that is moving outside
under a tent but they're still doing
a repertory um this summer which is
unlike last summer when they were
shuttered
thank you very much representative
southwood
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
a following up for ways and means for
our estimates
um i'm concerned about a group that you
didn't really mention today
and that is the group that refuses to
follow any of the safety recommendations
we also have some groups who are not
going to take the vaccine
and often it sounds like we're having an
optimistic view of
progress which i certainly support but
we have people
actively working against progress and i
think that must be hard for you to
factor in
thank you thank you and and that is true
it is
um you know we have folks that for
whatever reason choose not to follow the
common sense safety measures that we've
all been following
for the past year wearing our mask
watching our distance washing our hands
you know that same old tired you know i
think we're all tired a year later we
are all have covered fatigue
we don't love it um but we know that if
we want to get to
the other side we're going to have to do
it and you know and right now
especially as we get towards the end of
winter here and we can sort of envision
that there could be spring happening
um and summer um you know i think most
of us are anxious to take off those
masks
um and especially as we get vaccinated
but it's going to be really
important for us to double down and stay
vigilant
around some of those very basic things
that we should all be doing
in order to keep all of us safe so that
we can get those businesses open so that
we can go out and have those
outdoor activities and you know have
time at the beach or time in the
mountains
um and you know stop in and get a coffee
at our favorite coffee shop
and make sure that we can so you know we
anticipate that we're going to still
have
some things that are not normal um
but um you know we need everyone's
um cooperation and vigilance
to get us moving in the right direction
and really that means thinking about
what you do in those
informal groups businesses have done a
tremendous job
of adapting their business processes to
be able to be safe for their employees
and the
customers and their public that comes in
them for the most part they've just
really done a great job
um it's sometimes we get a little bit um
you know when when we are in among our
family and friends in those informal
gatherings
is you know we found that that's really
the time that we let our guard down
and we take those masks off and we get
too close and that's when we begin to
see
spread follow-up
follow-up thank you so just uh um
again you said it very well we need
everyone's cooperation
to have this outlook for summer and so
on but we do not
and so it just makes me think for ways
and means that the problem is going to
go on
longer because we do not have that
cooperation
yeah yes
you know you know again we have no magic
crystal ball of what
what the exact amount of time will be
but we need everyone's cooperation
we've worked closely with um you know
even health officers and communities and
even our attorney general's office to
provide education
to um you know business owners so that
they can do the right thing
and we we need folks to um pay attention
and really work together as a community
for us all to move forward
thank you i have a question you've
addressed it once they heard immunity
well the way things are going right now
the progress that you're making
when do and if it continues that way
when do you think we may be hitting
the herd immunity point great thank you
thank you representative major chair
um you know it's unclear
as as i've said i think everything i've
said today is unclear so i'm a very
unsatisfactory um
speaker for you today i think um but
um we you know the experts are saying
something like 70 75
is the sort of classic sense of hurt
immunity
to be vaccinated um i we don't
know how you know i can't give you the
mathematical formula for that because i
don't know the
amount of vaccine that we're going to
have available and people's uptake of
that vaccine
those are the wild cards in that
calculation
um you know as i mentioned earlier the
governor
is suggest he's he's not he's
um considering the fact that we may not
get there but that will
have enough other protective practices
um
in place to get us closer to you know
reopening some of those businesses or
allowing businesses to have some more
flexibility so vaccine and herd immunity
is
an important tool in the toolbox but it
is not everything as
as we were just noting you know we're
going to continue for
you know at least some time now that
we're going to need to wear masks
in when we're around people that are not
in our pod
and we're going gonna need to social
distance um for a little bit longer
um in order to get through this
especially as we try and get those
those people vaccinated you know i i
think some of the numbers
um we're at 11 12 12 probably right
now of new hampshire being um having at
least one dose
that's a long way away from 70 but we
are
you know we have appointments every day
for people getting vaccinated
and you know our main goal right now is
to get those most
at risk vaccinated um because that's
you know ethically and and even
economically and the impact to our
health care system we need to make sure
that those most at risk are not in our
hospitals or
have the worst of the outcomes of
commitment so i'm sorry i don't have a
number for you
that has to do with
isn't the public health system
uh giving out examples
more that if you don't wear a mask this
is what's going to happen to the
surrounding air that somebody else is
going to be breathing i don't see any of
that
but the things that people have told me
is that the droplets get into the air
they spread out the more windy it is
the more they go and that doesn't seem
to be publicized
enough i think if it was publicized
enough
people might change their mind about
whether or not
so is there why isn't publicized in us
um thank you for that question i think
we have tried and certainly cdc has lots
of great
pieces of information out there we know
those respiratory droplets you know
i wear my mask um to keep
you know you safe it also provides a
layer of protection for me
um i think um those droplets go out
there and then they drop
um although we do know that there's
still some aerosol that floats
in the in the air which is why things
like ventilation systems are so
important indoors um i think it's
complex
um and i think people do not like
wearing masks
um that's probably the the you know the
most obvious thing i've said all day
people don't like it
um it's um you know it can be
uncomfortable although i think many of
us
um you know uh can't even imagine right
now a time where you look at a movie or
a tv show and you see people in a
you know bar or restaurant close
together with no mask that was pretty
foreign at this point of why would
anyone ever have done that
before so i think you're right i think
we need to continue to stay
on message and let people know um
what they can do to protect themselves
um we certainly heard about a week or
two ago there was a
little bit of a bubble in the media
around double masking
and you know some of the benefits that
could be conveyed with double masking
especially
wearing a like a a lighter sort of
hospital grade mask
um the procedure mask in 95 but you know
the little procedure mask with the
cloth mask on top of it as we are um
you know to provide perhaps even more
protection with those new variants
floating around
um but if you are correct we may need to
go back to the beginning and remind
people why it is that we're doing all of
these things in the first place
well thank you patricia that was
a great presentation he made and
and all the answers to the various
questions i think
will help out the committee here but
i don't okay there's one more hand up um
representative elliot uh thank you mr
chairman
i want to apologize to director tilley
for being so abrupt
uh that was most on gentlemanly of me
so i apologize i'm sure it's well taken
thank you thank you and you provide us
your slides
yes i will send those over to
christopher wright when i get off and i
will provide that
case definition for the cdc case
definition as well thank you very much
thank you now committee we're going to
have to get back to
yes have
come in the the dra representatives
questions
and chris could you bring up
so the the worksheet i just brought up
is the same worksheet that represent
major
um sent out yesterday to i think all the
committee members
the only difference this there's three
things that i adjusted
where it said hi lo house ways and means
low and high estimates
there was no designation ever that was
the republican estimate so i put that in
there
i provided a another row so that when
the committee comes to an agreement that
it'll be clearly
noted in the documents and i bolded it
so you can see there's already some
areas where the committee has come to
some agreement on the revenue estimates
and then the last thing i did is i just
renumbered the rows
so that you can reference a row number
uh the bolded one two
three four um you know whichever one you
might need to so those are the only
changes
that were made to the document that
represent major sent out to you uh
yesterday
okay um i think we might as well
go right to the business taxes which is
we are tough this month
and in the data we have the
republicans estimates for the low and
the high
we have the democrats estimate which is
the
medium of their low and high
and then we have a line says
the governor's estimate minus
the republicans median and then the
governor's
estimate minus the dam medium
the dens estimate and then which set
which shows that if you have a negative
number
such as on line
21 at 600 000
which means the governor is less
i'm sorry it means the governor is
higher sorry
no it's it's less because it's the
governor
minus so
the republican medium is greater than
the governor
by 600 000. in line 22
is greater than governor by
estimate should be or
or why the estimates are such as that
the six hundred thousand dollars on the
republican medium is so darn close
but the fifty one hundred uh five point
one million dollars
difference on the dens
is there somebody that might want to
explain that
represent almond and
i didn't want to explain that i was
hoping to get
okay we have the dra here
yeah there's that we're talking about uh
21 at this point so it's just question
about whether there are original
changes about on taking
the revenues down due to
as assuming that the extension payments
and returns
in march to april were going to come
in on lower uh
were going to come in as lower than
what on they usually would do
because right now we're on track to some
somebody the dra want to address that
sure good morning for good morning mr
chair for the record melissa rollins
senior financial analyst
um i also have on me on here with me
devon rodrick
um financial analyst and carolyn lear
assistant commissioner
uh thank you for the question
representative elmi um
i think we i agree with you there has
been some great performance so far for
business taxes
i think we are still hesitant
at looking at what those returns and
extensions may be
it's a little bit tough because we
haven't been in this situation before
with covid as you know so
normally we can pretty much correlate
what estimates are looking like and
tie that out to returns and extension
payments and we have a pretty good idea
how the year is going to end and a
pretty good way to model it
however we are hesitant that
in what we've heard anecdotally and this
may be for some of the smaller and
medium-sized businesses versus the
larger businesses
is that a lot of the estimate payments
were made based on
um estimate payments last year
and if that's the case if these
businesses did take a loss we're gonna
see that true up come in
in march and april on these returns and
extension payments
uh that may be the same for large
businesses i think we're still sort of
keeping an eye on them although we do
know some businesses have been
performing well
we do see the news articles in the
online saying they've been performing
well but we just don't know how much of
that is going to be offset by any
decreased
lost felt during this covid uh covid
period
so you are correct i think i had sent an
email yesterday to you concerning this
that our low
does have a reduction of 18 for returns
and extensions
and that is based on some modeling we
were able to do
based on the last recession even though
i know they are not similar so we did
make some
economic adjustments to match this
session
so i think that is definitely our low
and we're feeling
as more data comes in that that low
might be too low especially with some of
the offset that we've received
this month and then in our high we still
did
account for a loss but at half that loss
at nine percent for returns and
extension payments
again i just want to know um we've
worked with you for
for many years on revenue estimates and
this by far
is definitely our hardest year to
estimate this out
so feel free to um ask any further
questions
or or land where you feel it's necessary
to land because it is
it is a challenging situation this year
we have nothing to model it up after
let me say some words on the framework
here
is that it would be nice to be able to
do a house resolution this week
if we don't finish this and then we
won't do a house resolution this week
we would just give the
finance committee a range we we have to
remember
that march and april are
the ones that really tell us better than
anything else
what the revenues are really going to be
for the
end of fy21
and it would be that would be the basis
of going forward to fy 22 and
23. so we will be looking
at the revenues and making
adjustments every month
so what we if we give the revenues to
the house resolution
today they will be
adjusted on the basis of
how the economy changes in a month
in march i mean in april and then in may
in june and right up to the time we do
the committee a conference
with the senate on the final budget
passing
because the whole thing is so volatile
one
one big thing we haven't even hit yet
is that congress is going to come up
with
a super super
stimulus package 1.9 trillion dollars
and we're not sure what that's going to
entail
and that may throw everything out of
whack it
may be for the good i would assume
and for that but we don't know that yet
but we will know that
hopefully within the month
of what congress is passing so the whole
thing is volatile
but i want you to know that because of
the volatility
we will every month we be adjusting our
revenue estimates
but we need to get something to the
finance committee so they have a goal
so what do we need to do
i've got a question okay
james did you did you say representative
ames
yes i did oh i'm sorry i didn't hear um
yeah uh this is a question about um a
single number or two numbers
and um i say at the outset it would be
helpful to know
if the republican caucus is
willing or ready or whether we need to
have a lot of conversation around
this question of of trying to reach to
a single number and then just a word or
two about the democrats
using coming coming forward with a
single number
it's not that uh that we all agree
um i think it's more that
we all agree that there's there's
uncertainty
and uh there's a lot here that
serves beyond our powers of prediction
it's that crystal ball that was
referenced in the
previous presentation um there
are so many different variables that
come to bear that and it's what uh dra
just said
they've never seen a year as difficult
as this one
uh or as uh a uh biennium as
as difficult as this one to estimate for
uh
so i think we we felt that
we a single number
in the in the middle of the rough range
that we thought was reasonable
taking uh taking giving significant
weight to what dra had done
because uh they spend more time on this
and
uh worry about it more perhaps we all
worry about it i shouldn't say that but
uh the they uh uh
are have come forward with uh estimates
that should be given credibility so
um that's that's background for for our
moving to a single number
and back to my original question
and whether we can all get to a single
number
yeah i think that's the way the
republican caucus would like to go
towards a single number and then if that
is different then maybe we could put the
difference it's not going to make that
much difference right now because
and and the numbers that we come up with
for fy
so you're talking something like about
five and a half million dollars
now the middle would be two and a half
minutes
i wouldn't have a problem with that i
wouldn't either mr chair
yeah thank you um look we only have five
revenue streams that are in contention
and each one of those is three three
numbers three different votes
so we got we're talking about 15 votes
uh
most of them are pretty close
uh democrats and republicans are
actually pretty close
so i'm in the camp of with the exception
of
23 fiscal year 23 business taxes
uh we have to have a discussion on that
one but all the other ones i think we
could just split the difference
uh i have the numbers i just i took the
the democrat average
and the republican average add them
together divide by two
for instance or 21
that would be 107.5 million for
20 21 for republicans
and 812 million for democrats
so that average is 109.75
you don't mean 109. i i would simply
move
let's go with 109.75 i mean
800 809 i'm sorry
before we move stuff on
we had on first
i would if we were not going to a single
number i would go to wider
ranges than what we had so
there is too much uncertainty um
but we had on
at least eight million worth of
anomalies
i believe on melissa told
representative ames on a couple of days
ago
in february and they don't have anything
to do with 22 but
they are there in 21.
um she was talking about
maybe um maybe the 18
off was a little too much i've been
thinking about the ppe
uh effects that we've already had
and uh though we we are taxing them at
this point but
on the tax on them is pretty minor stuff
uh for the amount they got
and on
i would i really think
that on the
[Music]
the number in the middle is a lot closer
to the one that the democrats came up
with
then than that thank you
so are you saying that we don't
look
yeah i i personally would object to that
i think we're ending
at at least at what the democrat
democratic estimate was which is
uh 10 million 12 million less than the
and the agency numbers are are more
recent
and just of affirmed as
as more recent uh than the governors
were
you know you can put 20
and they make an estimate and probably
almost everyone will be a little
different and what do they do
they'll end up getting rid of the
outliers
and coming up with an average for one
number
that's the same procedure that
recommending here
each caucus looked at these things
weighted all the
evidence and came up with their ranges
and made them
with the range and so
the recommendation is should we split
that
now represent ames
but
who
splitting the differences between
on the business taxes let's say
taking the average of splitting the
difference the average between the
republicans and democrats
explain that difference who would not
agree to that you know if you don't want
to agree just raise your hand
into faith by it raising your hand
uh i didn't hear the question clearly uh
could you remember and you can't see it
again and maybe talk louder
is that
agreeing to taken the difference between
the averages of the republicans
and the average of the democrats
splitting the
taking that number as our first
and i think and ruxin aims
you agree with that procedure
yes i do okay
and who doesn't agree with that
procedure just
we click the raised hand if we don't
well the raised hands go to the top and
oh there's a single number you're asking
us to read you maybe you need to repeat
the number
and so i think it's important that you
repeat the number
okay if we take the
number the midpoint
of the republican number yes
midpoint for the democrat number
and we find out what the difference is
and we split it in order to be able to
come up with
one number that we both agree on this is
our
first number it's appointment
[Music]
can you say the number okay and you did
the um
[Music]
hey um chris would you populate what
i have 809.75 but
i have that as well right so 809.75
yup that's what i got as well
so 0.9.75
i certainly can agree with that
one of the things is who doesn't and
they look like a boat afterwards on
everything but right now i want to show
our hands who does not agree with that
number
do you want that in the raised hand
function or do you actually want people
to raise their hands on the screen
because we're still sharing a screen
and then we have one understand
so we'll go over the 809.8
for fy21
fy22
what would that be we're a lot closer on
this one
yeah the republicans are
825 825 million
uh or billion 825
and um democrats are at 8 28. we're very
close
very close so just take the average
now this one
it's going to be very wild it's the most
volatile than there is
everything is going to get thrown at us
the result of the uh
of the stimulus ones uh the pandemic
we vary by 10 million dollars and i'd
say let's split the difference
so i think susan almighty has her hand
thank you on a single sales factor is
current law
i don't know whether you've included
that in your thoughts
i included that and market-based
sourcing from
what the dra sent
on in my thoughts last night
and i on i increased it for market-based
sourcing
i decreased it for single sales factor
and i ended up with 835 again
so i really think that we need to
specifically
know that we are including single sales
factor
in there
would you um give us your thoughts
on including the central sales factor
sure i know we've had a lot of emails
going back and forth
um and this is a tricky and tough topic
uh as you know when we've looked at this
before in the fiscal impact
it is indeterminable on our side
we've we've talked some about
market-based sourcing and how um we've
have
we have a memo out there actually that i
think you all have
uh that talks about we did look at a a
core sample
of taxpayers and i'll just explain a
little bit with market-based sourcing
that in order to determine a fiscal
impact for market-based sourcing which
went into effect
on january 1st of this year you really
need to look at taxpayers
records uh because it needs to be
audited and drilled down to see about
those
intangible sales so we were able to look
yeah
a small group representative represented
and audit was able to drill down and we
did come up with an estimated impact of
10 million
however that is a very rough estimate i
want to qualify that
because there are a lot of factors that
can play into that
based on how many people are now coming
in that we're gaining for market-based
sourcing and then how many people we are
losing as those sales are now
sourced to other states that were
previously sourced to us
so market-based sourcing i think we can
say
we think will potentially be a revenue
increaser
at a minimum level and how much we're
not sure if we did the 10 million
estimate it's rough but at least we can
give you that much
with single sales factor it gets a
little bit tricky
so that current law is set to go in
place on january 1st
of next year 2022. uh we also have a
memo on that which you've seen and i
believe we've sent around to everybody
the first
the latest fiscal impact that we did
which was in october
it's again if you look at it tricky
because one we don't have market based
sourcing returns in yet to compare
what the single sales factor will look
like for these new taxpayers
we only can really do a an analysis
based on
the old cost of performance method so we
did do that because we're trying to
attempt to get some information out to
you guys
and then looking at that you can see
that it does swing
in the first few years that we look at
it it does swing positive to negative
a pretty a pretty good amount so in 2014
looking at it
it was a 9.7 million dollar revenue
increase
and then in 17
it was a 17 million dollar decrease and
in 18 because we know there was a large
large increase in revenues a large
federal tax reform
repatriated returns were filed
it's a 68.2 million dollar decrease in
revenue
again that's under the cost of
performance not the market-based
sourcing
and it's difficult to tell because of
this swing and what the taxpayers are
going to do
in future years and what their sales are
going to look like whether it's going to
be a positive or a negative
based on what we've seen it looks like
it's a negative loss on more
of the years than the positive gain
however
what that loss looks like and if there
will be a loss is
is really indeterminable for us we have
no way to see it because of these two
separate laws coming in hand in hand
however once we do have a year of
market-based records
in hand we'll be able to look at those
records and say what a single
sales analysis would look like
so this one is tricky we don't have a
definitive answer
we've tried to slice and dice it and we
it's just
indeterminable and we'll have better
information
from the end of april once the
march and april revenues are coming in
but still it's going to be
dicey and uh
i'd rather be on the conservative side
on this
and i'd go along with splitting it right
so they
there's 10 million dollar difference so
it'd be 20
right down the middle would be 26.1
then
what would that final number be pat
i gotta calculate it because i was if
you think that's okay we'll go that way
um well let's see what the number looks
like
all right uh that's going to be going
splitting it down the middle okay so
democrat uh mithwine is 835.
right on representative major
yes could i ask
would you on go
to the floor with an explanation that
this
includes some idea of the losses
that could be there to single sales
factor or are you going to ignore it
entirely because
i do believe that there
uh it is likely that the situation will
be like the 18
one with major
corporations having major profits and
that there will be losses on
and we are trying to get
the senate to delay implementation until
we know what we're doing
and being able to go
to to the floor
including that in the estimate would
help
with that regard thank you right and
delaying
uh it won't affect what we're trying to
do right now
because we still have to use the current
law
but anyway yes it's the current law
so the current law
says that we are more likely than not to
be losing revenue
in 2023
yes and no and
but i think with the two caucuses
meals and rooms the difference between
the midpoint of the
republicans and democrats is is two
million dollars
what would be the result
is the number okay 302 for republicans
300 for
democrats uh averages to 301
okay and then uh
we're in agreement on the
and again we're so close
so the average the average is uh
the uh republican number is uh 350
democrat numbers 349.
so the average would be 349.5
i mean we're almost identical
okay let me see does anybody have a
problem
tobacco the difference
is two and a half million dollars
between the republicans and the
democrats
yeah republican the republican average
was
uh 246.5
and the democrats were 249.
247.8 20. you know okay
wait a minute yeah 247.8 yep
[Music]
and i mean there's a very small
difference
on fy22 so what would that result in
[Music]
244.75
244.8
there's a three million dollar swing so
the average would be
240.5
okay the liquor transfer an agreement
[Music]
and then interesting dividend
we're pretty close there's 500 it's a
republicans are 128.5 the democrats are
very close so the average would be
there's a half a million dollar
it should be 130 do you have a number on
that
which one are you on the second year now
sec for fiscal 22 yes
uh okay so republicans were at uh
136 and the democrats were at 137 again
very close
man off the average of those would be
136.5
that's
i think that communication republicans
are like 137
on the interest in dividend yeah on
interesting dividends
now for the communication let's
aim for everybody
i think we're all agreed yeah and then
for real estate is a half a million
dollar difference between us
yep uh uh republicans were at 190
1.5 democrats were 192.
you know again very close so the average
would be
it would be 180.25 is it 180.3
right then the last number
is 23 for transfer
uh republicans were at 170.5
for their average democrats were at 167.
okay and that's those are all the
numbers
any questions or comments
on what we did on coming up for the
numbers for the house resolution
great job i think with all of the
different factors
really i think we did about the best we
could
and we're going to have to do it again
and again and again
as we get more and more information
um so then we need to take a
roll call vote on this so
yes chris um
did you want to do a roll call vote for
each of the funding sources or did you
want to do one vote at the end
for general fund education trust fund
highway fund and fish and game
oh yeah right it was
okay i'd rather do the whole bit at once
in the highway fund
[Music]
the republicans are going to accept the
agency's numbers
are you going to accept the agency
represent almighty
i believe that's what we said somebody
remind me
if we had any quibbles
i don't think we had quibbles i i don't
think we spent time on it but
if if somebody had equivalent we would
have spent time on it
yeah we did look at it i did it
okay
and fish and game the committee agreed
to last week to the numbers that are in
here
then let's just look at the at the total
the fishing game sorry let's go look at
the total for
if you can yeah that's it
so that fy 22 the total comes up to be
2.674
2.725 and that's a growth
2.755 and that's about
um relative to the coverage number
we don't care whatever for me
these are our numbers but for
this is
we didn't do it on our numbers
does anybody who changes it
more any changes that you want to make
then i'd like to have representative
bernstein follow the role
our role will be to accept
the estimates that we have for the
general and education trust fund
the highway fund and the fishing game
fund
i'll stop sharing my screen so you can
okay uh representative major do we need
a motion or just go right to the vote
um we need a motion okay
okay
and the motion is ought to pass through
the general fund and education trust
fund
the highway front and the fishing game
all in favor when your name is paul
saying yes
would you disagree no representative
bernstein
thank you mr chair let's begin the roll
call vote with representative abrami
yes mary griffin
representative griffin not voting
representative hollery yes ober
sorry sorry about that yes man yeah fred
can you show me your
your face absolutely
don't make me sorry
[Laughter]
you're on mute bob
yes thank you representative
yes representative nunes yes
representative baxter yes billsbury
representative
i'm going to record your vote as yes
representative almighty
yes ames yes southward
yes malloy yes schamberg
representative schamberg votes yes
tucker
representative chucker votes yes go
marlo
yes laughman representative laughman
no vote um representative gorg
yes hacken phillips
murphy yes chairman major
yes mr chair the vote is 22 in favor
zero opposed two members did not vote
well the vote been 22-0 the motion about
to pass
passes who uh i'm sorry who made the
uh second on that motion ames absolutely
ames
thank you well
i thank everybody it's this is not easy
but we have to come to a compromise
and we know we're going to get a number
of more
bites of the apple as we get more
information
and hopefully as we get more information
it's going to be positive
we've had enough negative information to
last a lifetime
but anybody else need any want to make
yeah i thought it was very helpful to
have someone from
the department of health and human
services
that although i didn't like hearing what
she had to say
sometimes it was very helpful thank you
for pursuing that
she knew her business didn't she yes
and uh and she was willing to take the
slings and arrows
when i talked to the commissioner about
getting somebody here
and she was sent a real good present
or any other comments from anybody
then uh i i do have a comment
if any of the bills that we have on
consent calendar
gets pulled off those that made the
motion
and i've sent your name in i'm get up to
speak to defend that bill
and then i'll do the pi hopefully
we won't have any of these bills pulled
off to consent but be prepared
as if they're going to be pulled off
consent
and then next week on tuesday
and wednesday all the remaining bills
we are going to have a work session and
those that we can take care of
on on tuesday and we'll exact them out
and we need a further amendment for that
and we'll take care of them on wednesday
of those that we feel that we don't have
enough time to fix them
and and we would like to
work on them and we'll vote to retain
them
and those that we don't like will just
but the discussion that people have had
on
house bill 15 has been a very
interesting discussion this
led to areas that i hadn't considered
myself and
so i think we're there so
any questions yes
representative romney so um um yes chris
do you think oh when will all uh ols
have this uh
so the intention is to give them um a
draft
resolution by noon today okay i've
already talked to them last week and
they've got a shell
lsr set up in the format that your
resolutions typically are
so i expect it would be fairly quick
this afternoon
so it could go tomorrow then some of
that depends on um
how many amendments and other things
that they're drafting right now
related to the session or other
committees that are doing work
so that that's the one factor but i did
let them know i needed something by the
end of today
so the representative major could have
that and take a look at it and share
with whoever he needs to share with
and then getting it on your agenda for
attention is to have
thursday night
and then uh i would like to have
representative
i would be happy to do that we're going
to be in
opposite ends of the hall it sounds like
doesn't sound like a hall it sounds like
yeah i got a question not a question a
comment so tomorrow
when we do consent calendar pay
attention after
the consent vote because then the the uh
clerk is going to start reading off
names of committees that
these the second committee bills are
going to
so i usually try to keep track of of how
many bills we're going to get
when off the consent and then after each
one of the bills is passed out of the
you know the other non non-consent bills
after the debate and if it passes then
the
the last thing the speaker will do is
say this this bill is going to ways of
means or this bill is going to finance
it gives you it'll give you a pretty
good idea how many bills we're going to
have to deal with in the next couple of
weeks
that's all uh patrick
if you could get the clerk to do what i
could not get the clerk to do
and read off the name of the committee
things are going to
before he reads off all of the numbers
of bills that would be so helpful
right what's committee first and then
all right and we'll see you all
tomorrow in person great
thank you everybody thank you mr chair